[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Patrice doré bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être sur ce plateau vous êtes le
président des Restos du coeur on en
parlait à l'instant des restos qui
lancent aujourd'hui leur 38e campagne
sur fond de précarité aggraver en France
on l'a vu dans le reportage c'est un cri
d'alarme que vous lancez ce matin oui un
cri d'alarme parce qu'effectivement ce
que l'on constate aujourd'hui est inédit
c'est une augmentation assez forte ces
derniers mois de la précarité et du
nombre de personnes que nous accueillons
puisque 12% de personnes en plus
accueillies par les Restos du coeur je
rappelle l'échelle les Restos du Coeur
c'était l'an dernier un million 100000
personnes et 142 millions de repas donc
12% de personnes accueillies en plus
c'est effectivement un chiffre
inquiétant et notre inquiétude elle va
au-delà puisque nous avons quelques
incertitudes et notamment quand à
l'inflation à la hausse des prix qui
fera fortement les plus modestes de ce
pays on va y revenir dans un pendant que
les Restos ont quasiment 40 ans enfin
dans quelques années ils auront 40 ans
de mémoire de resto on n'a jamais vu ça
non on n'a jamais vu ça on a eu bien
évidemment des crises à affronter
notamment la crise de 2008 avec 15%
d'augmentation la première année et 25%
au-delà des trois ans c'est 25 % sont
toujours là et effectivement aujourd'hui
ce que l'on constate c'est une
augmentation qui est très limitée dans
le temps et qui concerne des publics qui
sont des publics que l'on aimerait pas
avoir de main et notamment la petite
enfance avec des bébés des bébés qui
sont accueillis fortement au resto du
coeur puisque un bébé qui naît dans une
famille pauvre sur quatre est accueilli
au Resto du Coeur aujourd'hui il y a des
bébés beaucoup de les amis mono parental
de femmes qui sont seules avec leurs
enfants beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent aussi beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent beaucoup de jeunes
50% de ces personnes là au moins de 25
ans donc une population qui nous
préoccupe également et puis des
travailleurs précaires qui effectivement
qui viennent nous voir à un moment du
mois qui est de plus en plus tôt parce
que leur ressources ne sont pas
suffisantes et parce qu'aujourd'hui
quand on enlève de ces ressources là qui
sont parfois assez faibles le prix de
loyer puisse le prix de l'énergie qui
coûte de plus en plus cher effectivement
aujourd'hui et bien comme 60% des
personnes que l'on accueille on vit avec
la moitié du seuil de pauvreté
c'est-à-dire avec moins de 551 euros par
mois donc la campagne commence
aujourd'hui les années précédentes vous
aviez quoi un million 100000 un million
200000 bénéficiaires cette année ça sera
encore plus de quoi ont-ils besoin ceux
qui viennent vous voir
déjà ils ont besoin d'une écoute d'une
main tendue c'est pas facile de franchir
la porte d'une association de solidarité
de venir au resto du coeur il y a
toujours ce phénomène de honte cette
stigmatisation qui est insupportable
donc déjà besoin d'écoute et puis besoin
d'une aide alimentaire c'est évident
aujourd'hui c'est de la survie et
au-delà de cette aide alimentaire ce que
l'on essaie de leur apporter aussi c'est
de l'accompagnement de l'aide à la
personne avec différentes activités le
soutien à la recherche d'emploi par
exemple
l'accompagnement budgétaire scolaire et
puis une forme d'écoute qui leur permet
aussi de reprendre confiance en eux et
surtout nous ce que l'on cherche c'est
que ces personnes là nous quittent le
plus vite possible et elle aussi elles
ont envie de vous quitter le plus vite
possible évidemment vous l'avez dit vous
ne faites effectivement c'est bien de le
rappeler ce matin vous ne faites pas que
si j'ose dire des dons alimentaires mais
vous accompagnez aussi sur des projets
professionnels sur des des
accompagnements sociaux vous avez en
face de vous vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure des gens qui viennent de subir
plusieurs crises la crise sanitaire là
les conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
qu'est-ce que ça fait peser ça sur le
sur le lien social
aujourd'hui on a nos 70 000 bénévoles on
n'a pas le droit de ne pas sourire faire
que on a l'obligation de rester souriant
confiant et d'accueillir ces personnes
pour leur redonner confiance il y a une
véritable inquiétude qui existe
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que sera le notre
lendemain parce que on n'en voit pas le
bout vous l'avez dit on sort d'une crise
sanitaire on a encore des conséquences
de cette crise qui pour les personnes
les plus modestes les avaient fortement
touchés et on attaque tout de suite
derrière une crise une crise
inflationniste sur des produits
essentiels aujourd'hui sans pouvoir se
déplacer pour travailler pour se former
pour aller éventuellement un rendez-vous
médical ce n'est plus possible et les
personnes que l'on rencontre ont ce
choix là à faire tous les jours à nous
de les rassurer et les aider pour s'en
sortir au plus vite il y a une forme de
désarroi qui s'accentue au fil du temps
oui une forme de lassitude mais
d'inquiétude face à toutes ces
incertitudes là pour l'instant tout ce
que l'on constate nous c'est que toutes
ces personnes là ont quand même la
volonté de s'en sortir c'est ça qui est
important jusqu'à quand je n'en sais
rien vous parliez de vos bénévoles donc
70 000 personnes qui chaque année
participent avec vous au resto et sans
qui bien sûr cette campagne ne pourrait
pas avoir lieu mais votre inquiétude
elle est liée aussi au fait que c'est
bénévoles sont eux aussi touchés par
l'inflation qui augmente les coûts du
carburant est-ce que ça ça vous inquiète
aussi sur le fonctionnement
on a des bénévoles qui parcourent la
France tous les jours pour aller
prospecter chercher des produits
alimentaires chez des producteurs locaux
ou dans des magasins pour faire de la
formation puisque nos équipes sont
formées et aujourd'hui c'est bénévoles
nous disent moi j'ai plus les moyens de
me déplacer il existe une mesure fiscale
qui existe déjà depuis longtemps qu'il a
réduction d'impôts qui est autorisée qui
est accordée par la loi sur les les
dépenses de déplacement des bénévoles
mais pour ça il faut être imposable
alors est-ce que le bénévolat est
réservé qu'à ceux qui ont les moyens non
aujourd'hui un bénévole donne beaucoup
de temps sont souvent des sacrifices
personnels on ne peut pas lui demander
de donner de l'argent qu'il a pas pour
lui-même donc solution et c'est un
investissement social c'est pas une
dépense publique uniquement c'est de
transformer cette réduction d'impôts en
crédit d'impôts de façon à ce qu'on soit
complètement égalitaire entre tous les
bénévoles et surtout qu'on puisse se
préserver de maintenir un tissu
associatif qui est important aujourd'hui
un euro d'argent public investi dans
l'association chez nous au resto du
coeur c'est 5 à 6 euros que l'on peut
déployer sur le terrain grâce justement
et à la générosité du public et à la
présence de nos bénévoles ça c'est une
demande que vous faites absolument on
parlait de l'augmentation du coût de
l'essence elle impacte bien sûr les
bénéficiaires des restos mais aussi les
bénévoles à nouveau car et ça c'est
peut-être nouveau et c'est aussi une
illustration de cette de la façon dont
la précarité
augmente géographiquement sur le
territoire vous vous êtes rendu compte
qu'il ne fallait plus faire que des
distributions en ville mais allez de
plus en plus dans les territoires ruraux
et là ça vous coûte donc non seulement
il y a cette première observation et par
ailleurs ça vous coûte encore plus cher
aujourd'hui on a vous constater lors de
la crise sanitaire que beaucoup de
personnes démunies précaires
n'osaient plus déplacées parce que
crainte de la maladie et puis aussi
problème déjà à l'époque de déplacement
aujourd'hui c'est même personne là nous
disent mais moi je ne peux plus me
déplacer vers vos centres de d'activités
parce que je n'ai pas les moyens de
mettre de l'essence dans mon véhicule et
on avait à l'époque déjà des véhicules
qu'on appelle les centres itinérants qui
nous permettent d'aller vers les
personnes en difficulté dans la ruralité
nous en avions 26 et dès l'an dernier
nous avons dit bon on va faire x 2 parce
que c'est un besoin dans toutes ces
zones blanches aujourd'hui nous sommes à
44 centre qui sont soit déployés soit
dans les véhicules sont en commun pas de
chance avec les difficultés qu'on les
constructeurs aujourd'hui ça prend un
peu de retard et l'idée c'est d'avoir
presque fois trois puisque nous avons 34
projets qui sont dans les tiroirs sauf
qu'ils ne pourront être déployés que
quand nous aurons des moyens pour les
financer et des bénévoles pour équiper
ses véhicules et là aussi ce sont des
charges importantes pour l'association
puisque ces véhicules il faut rouler il
faut mettre du carburant de et ça c'est
des frais que nous payons aussi l'enjeu
pour
c'est d'empêcher que les gens se
recroquevillent d'une certaine façon
dans
leur regard ce sont souvent les les
bénévoles des Restos du cœur que ces
personnes rencontrent dans un petit
village sur la place du village dans une
salle communale mis à notre dispositions
se sont parfois et souvent les seules
personnes qu'elle rencontre de la
journée ce lien social il est important
ça nous permet aussi de détecter des
besoins qu'elle n'arrive pas forcément à
exprimer un accès au droit un accès au
numérique par exemple mais on a
l'impression du coup que la charge qui
repose sur vous est immense est-ce que
vous vous dites parfois vous Patrice
doré vous ne devriez pas avoir à faire
ça que vous vous comblez un vide laissé
par voilà peut-être une action publique
qui a abandonné certains territoires en
tout cas ce vide il existe forcément
puisque quand Coluche a créé les Restos
du Coeur 1985 la première année nous
avions distribué 8 millions et demi de
repas aujourd'hui c'est 142 millions
c'est 17 fois plus donc on voit bien
effectivement que le rôle des Restos du
cœur malheureusement est encore présent
on aimerait être le seul resto on est
presque les seuls restos qui aimeraient
fermer et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
possible on voit bien et c'est notre
volonté encore une fois malgré les
doutes que nous avons
cette volonté notre responsabilité c'est
de rester présent et surtout de ne pas
diminuer l'aide que l'on apporte les
restos en 85 sur l'antenne d'Europe 1 il
était loin de penser que c'était une
idée qui allait durer il était loin de
le penser c'était pour lui la juste une
petite cantine le temps d'anniversaire
parce que il s'agirait que dans le pays
de la bouffe comme il disait on ouvre
les yeux et qu'on soit capable de donner
à manger à tout le monde aujourd'hui ce
n'est toujours pas le cas et
probablement qu'effectivement c'était
certainement pas dans son idée que les
Restos du Coeur seraient là longtemps
bien qu'il est déjà à l'époque donner
les premières les premières pistes vers
une loi qui n'a pas connu qui est la loi
Coluche qui permet aujourd'hui aux
donateurs de pouvoir effectivement
récupérer une partie de leurs dons on
est ici en France Patrice doré l'une des
plus grandes puissances mondiales vous
le disiez tout à l'heure plus d'un
enfant sur cinq vit aujourd'hui en
France sous le seuil de pauvreté il y a
aujourd'hui assez famille qui doit faire
des choix entre se déplacer ou se
nourrir se soigner ou se nourrir comment
est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là le choix
est plus difficile encore aujourd'hui
puisque le choix était avant entre le
tout et rien c'est à dire que quand on
savait faire des sacrifices sur quelque
chose à la limite on savait peut-être de
l'autre côté on avait on avait là on a
pas grand chose comment on allait
arriver là je ne sais pas aujourd'hui ce
qui est certain c'est que nous nous
sommes nous sommes là et nous resterons
là vous l'avez dit vous avez parlé
d'enfance la petite enfance est un
moment important les 1000 premiers jours
ça fixait les règles de l'éducation ça
parle de santé ça parle aussi de
relation et de lien social notre
ambition puisque nous accueillons 110000
bébés avec une forte augmentation ces
dernières ces derniers mois c'est
d'arriver dans les trois prochaines
années à pouvoir apporter l'aide
alimentaire à ses 110 000 bébés en
totalité et bien évidemment avec tout ce
que ça comporte des ateliers pour
apprendre aux mamans à utiliser ces
produits et puis surtout nous apporter
une aide à ces moments-là puisque
pendant qu'elle s'occupe de leur bébé
malheureusement très souvent elles font
un sacrifice pour elle-même et rien que
ce programme là sur les trois prochaines
années c'est entre 12 et 15 millions
d'euros il n'était pas question pour
nous de freiner ce programme alors
justement de quoi avez-vous besoin
aujourd'hui on parlait tout à l'heure de
ces actions que peut faire les pouvoirs
public qu'est-ce que peut faire ce qui
nous regardent pour vous alors du
soutien de l'État on l'a dit notamment
sur la question du crédit d'impôt
aujourd'hui nous aurons besoin de la
générosité du public notre crainte et
nous le respecterons c'est
qu'effectivement parmi nos donateurs
nous avons beaucoup de donateurs qui
font l'effort de données au reste du
cœur parce qu'ils ont confiance de
demain quel sera le niveau dedans je
n'en sais rien puisque beaucoup sont
modeste et encore une fois nous aurons
besoin de cette générosité de ceux qui
peuvent parfois il y en a qui peuvent
plus et on espère que ces personnes-là
seront généreuses aussi elles le sont
généralement avec les Restos du Coeur
bon et puis pour parler de choses
peut-être plus festives compliquées ces
dernières années à cause de la crise
sanitaire là le grand rendez-vous de
fait des restos elle est concert des
auront lieu cette année les
concerts auront lieu de cette année du
12 au 16 janvier à Lyon effectivement
deux années sans public la première
année c'était prévu la deuxième année à
Montpellier ce n'était pas prévu on a dû
quelques jours avant l'installation des
concerts annulée la présence du public
c'est une perte sèche de 4 millions
d'euros qui n'a pas été compensé en quoi
que ce soit aujourd'hui c'était un
rendez-vous important on retrouve notre
public les 42000 places se sont vendues
en 24 heures et puis les
au-delà de l'image et de ce rendez-vous
là c'est 8 à 10% des ressources des
Restos du cœur on voit bien que cette
année nous en aurons besoin il y a le
concert et puis après il y a bien sûr
les disques enfin
voilà je voudrais pas avoir ça
compte aux faire de don
S
à sa fuite trentaine trois W point
restos du cœur.org on peut aussi devenir
bénévole demain si on a du temps donné
donner du temps c'est important aussi
surtout quand on n'a pas les moyens de
donner de l'argent donc sur le même site
vous vous retrouvez toutes les pages
d'accueil de de notre de nos appels à
bénévolat c'est important vous l'avez vu
on aura besoin de renfort merci beaucoup
Patrice bourré d'être venu ce matin sur
le plateau de Paris direct alors que les
restos donc que vous présidez lancent
aujourd'hui leur 3
8 si encore